at least four people have been killed as
severe storms
lash central europe wind gusts of up to
181 kilometers per hour are being
reported gales battering northern
germany have created chaos for
transportation and they've knocked out
power supplies
a commuter ferry on the elba river close
to hamburg people here are used to
stormy weather but not to this
luckily no one here was seriously hurt
shipping for larger vessels has been
suspended in many coastal areas in
northern germany where storm elenia hit
particularly hard
rail traffic is also affected many long
distance trains in particular have been
cancelled causing major problems for
those traveling from hamburg or berlin
to munich for example
these cancellations are precautionary
measure because the safety of our
passengers and employees is our top
priority we don't want trains being
stuck on the open track in these weather
conditions because making sure 300 400
or 500 passengers on a train are safe is
difficult especially when the train is
also cut off from the power supply
collapsing trees posed the highest risk
for motorists several people were killed
when their cars were hit in germany and
neighboring countries like poland and
the czech republic
emergency services are advising people
to stay at home if they can
because the next storm is hot on the
heels of villania and zainab as it's
been called could be even more
destructive